aujourd'hui dans débat public vous avez
au saut modo deux discours qui
s'opposent vous avez le discours de la
décroissance qui consiste à dire que
pour réduire nos gaz à effet de serre il
faut nécessairement à baisser le niveau
de vie général de l'humanité des pays du
nord comme des pays du sud et puis vous
avez ceux comme moi qui pense au
contraire que la méthode la plus juste
et la plus efficace est de miser sur le
progrès économique et progrès
technologiques pourquoi je préfère la
solution du progrès économique et
technologique d'une part parce qu'il
faut rappeler que si on lutte contre le
changement climatique
ce n'est pas pour faire plaisir à gaya
c'est bien pour assurer la prospérité de
notre espèce c'est le but d'une boulaye
âge c'est le don de la terre oui c'est
pour le sait si on lutte contre le
changement climatique c'est bien pour
permettre aux êtres humains de jouir en
toute sûreté de leurs habitats tout en
bénéficiant du niveau de confort le plus
élevé possible idéalement c'est bien
dans ce sens que je considère que le
progrès économique et technologique
demeure le moyen le plus juste alors
maintenant est ce possible est ce un
mirage ou est ce possible quand on
regarde aujourd'hui les chiffres à
l'échelle internationale on remarque
qu'il n'ya pas de lien automatique entre
l'élévation du niveau de vie et les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre je
prends juste un exemple aujourd'hui un
français
consomme plus d'énergie qu'un chinois
car sud africain ou qu'un mongole et
pourtant il les met à la fois sur le
plan territorial mais aussi en matière
d'émissions importé moins de co2 qu'un
chinois cad sud africains ucca mongols
quelle est la variable la plus
déterminante ici c'est la variable
technologique on a des procédés
industriels qui ne dépendent pas des
mêmes énergie quand vous êtes un mongol
un chinois africains vous êtes très
dépendant du charbon en france une
grande partie même si c'est encore très
insuffisant de notre énergie c'est le
nucléaire qui est une énergie décarbonée
qui est d'ailleurs à mon sens l'énergie
la plus crédible si l'on veut offrir à
l'humanité le niveau de vie le plus
était possible tout en réduisant les gaz
à effet de serre puisque c'est la seule
témoigne à la seule énergie qui soit à
la fois d'état abonnés pilotable donc
disponible de jour comme de nuit
indépendamment de la météo et des
saisons et qu'ils aient fait preuve de
son efficacité à grande échelle or vous
voyez bien que le problème des pays
développés c'est la schizophrénie à
l'égard des mesures les plus efficaces
pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
[Musique]